la frc a le département de la réunion le
syndicat du sucre de la réunion nous
présente terre d'ici
pour
du haut de ses échasses nicolas cauwe
voit désormais son avenir professionnel
s'ouvrir vers de nouveaux horizons
demandeurs d'emploi et après une
expérience dans la restauration
il intègre voici deux mois cette
exploitation agricole de saint pierre un
changement de cap radical pour le jeune
homme qui a pu bénéficier en plus ici
deux contrats d'avenir
c'est un domaine qui me plaît vraiment
et je trouve ça bien d'avoir lancé ces
contrats là justement pour faciliter
aussi bien les agriculteurs que les
jeunes qui veulent se lancer là dedans
ou peu importe le métier en fait mais
l'agriculture c'est quelque chose que
jamais je redis que ça me plaisait mais
en fait ça me plait travail sous serre
c'est vraiment c'est un environnement
qui est quand même propre ses seins et
ça fait un bon travail
c'est un beau métier pendant trois ans
nicolas suivra ainsi également une
formation dans le domaine agricole
en attendant les premiers cours
théoriques qui débuteront très
prochainement
nicolas met déjà en pratique les
précieux conseils techniques de sandrine
et de bruno sur la culture du melon
quant à la couleur qui tourne aussi un
petit peu c'est une façon de repérer
aussi la maturité du manuel il devient
ivoire à mort alors il faut toujours
faire attention puisque tu en as des
restes couleur blanc vert et qui vont
être à maturité mais tu as quand même ce
critère de la beac lichaj voilà le plus
gros pourcentage ils vont tourner ivoire
nicolas apprend très vite et il est
assez minutieux dans son travail donc
c'est très intéressant pour nous et il
apprend très vite quoi on peut lui faire
une confiance entière on peut déjà le
laisser dans la serre à faire un
palissage est le bourgeollah jeu nous
fera pas de bêtises il
très très appliqué sur son travail est
très conscient sur dans ce cas là par
exemple là on peut voir un melon ici et
un autre qui est ici on va pas vraiment
retenir celui qui est là donc on va
compter deux filles à partir de celui là
donc une feuille de feuilles et très
délicatement enlevait juste le petit
coeur qui est juste ici pour que ce
melon puisse grossir convenablement fait
toute la force au lieu de se dispatcher
n'importe où
la force se passe vraiment se concentrer
dans le melon tout comme nicolas une
quinzaine de jeunes suivent actuellement
le même parcours de formation
professionnelle dans le monde agricole
une action rendue possible grâce au
groupement d'employeurs vive dalons dont
ils sont salariés
l'objectif au bout de trois ans et un
cdi c'est justement garder ces jeunes là
continuer à les faire progresser dans
l'entreprise donc soit l'agriculteur
embauche définitivement le jeune soit le
groupement d'employeurs continuant beau
chez ce jeune là et il va travailler
chez un agriculteur mais bien sûr que
l'objectif final est un cdi
oui on en a grandement besoin et pendant
ces trois ans justement ça nous permet
de le former à la politique de
l'entreprise
et puis ça nous permet d'avoir de la de
la main d'oeuvre qui nous permet de
continuer à développer notre entreprise
pour pouvoir l'embauché de trois ans
confronté un besoin de main d'oeuvre
qualifiée
des agriculteurs de la coopérative vivea
décide alors de créer voici trois ans un
groupement d'employeurs qu'il baptise
vive dalons pour répondre à leurs
attentes
nous sommes quelques maraîchers du plat
de fruits également mais nous avons
besoin de main d'oeuvre régulièrement
d'une main d'oeuvre spécialisée et donc
nous nous sommes mis en groupement pour
pouvoir mutualiser des ouvriers
spécialisés ou alors pour pouvoir former
de nouveaux salariés
à l'exemple de michel gigan qui a
intégré depuis peu l'exploitation avec
un contrat d'avenir de trois ans tout en
étant salarié du groupement d'employeurs
les nécessaires pour être efficaces à
l'expérience est là monsieur avec le
contrat d'avenir alors son compte dans
mon marchand ce2 des affronts de
travailler et de hawaï si des réformes
en plus pour être compétent dans le
travail va acquérir l'expérience
d'accueillir expérience et être formé
donc on est là sur un parcours qui est
intéressant parce que c'est un parcours
de formation en alternance où il ya d
acquisition de savoirs de base des
renforcements et également de la
formation technique il faut pas oublier
également que ce système permet aux
jeunes moins jeunes d'ailleurs d'avoir
une vision avec plusieurs entreprises
d'avoir plusieurs tâches donc la
formation ils vont l'acquérir beaucoup
plus rapidement
et puis à la formation interne en
parlais tout à l'heure avec les jeunes
c'est important d'avoir des tuteurs à
côté et la formation interne à la autant
de valeur en tout cas pour le fascia que
la formation externe
rx&d tort et william vitry sont eux deux
ouvriers expérimentés du groupement
d'employeurs en travaillant ainsi
régulièrement chez plusieurs exploitants
de la coopérative
ils partagent aussi leur expérience et
leur savoir faire avec les autres
ouvriers agricoles là vraiment c'est à
chaque fois d'autres cachent deux
nouveaux camps et puis de ne pas pouvoir
partager avec plusieurs personnes
une expérience à savoir faire et un
savoir vivre même voilà tout est
différent et puis c'est vraiment la
discussion la relation est plus bas et
puis on a l'expérience du travail on la
partage
de retour au pays
éric lui a pu ainsi faire valoir son
expérience métropolitaine dans ce
secteur d'activité mon travail c'est en
métropole concombres salades les ans
native tout ça et mon expérience vient
de là-bas quoi avant en arrivant ici on
était plus facile de trouver du boulot
quand la l'espérait danse ou cf comme ça
mais techniques sont pas les mêmes
méfaits la protéger ce que j'ai appris
là-bas pas le niveau des techniques
vraiment mais mon virage mais
travaillent tous à notre truc quoi c'est
le domaine là de temps en temps les cd m
le grand salon qu'il s'adapte mais c'est
pas facile parce qu'on peut pas changer
la méthode de travail aussi on croit que
tout le monde peut tout faire mais
finalement non là un bon ouvrier fait la
différence par son comportement par sa
capacité de voir pas ses gestes sa
douceur et donc on a vraiment besoin de
préparer
et de spécialiser les ouvriers
travaillent chez nous
tout